l'odyssée des boat people haïtiens mise
en théâtre par une compagnie de la
martinique au festival d'avignon le
spectacle se veut artistique et n'hésite
pas à mêler chant et danse sur scène ils
manifestaient pour réclamer les caves de
la radio si l'intérêt du spectacle et
dans sa mise en scène espace réduit de
l'embarcation et l'espace éclaté du pays
haïtien l'alternance autorise les allers
retours entre espoir et drame entre
imaginaire et réalité
créée il ya tout juste un an jouer cette
fois en martinique et une fois en
guadeloupe
les enfants de la mère ont trouvé un
nouveau public à avignon la culture qui
nous a varié tellement riche de par la
danse de par le chant départ notre vie
qui pourront et théâtre 1 de part notre
histoire de ce qu'on a pu en fait vivre
donc tout est important pour moi
avec la compagnie des enfants de la mer
on s'invective et on chante en français
en créole mais aussi en arabe avec amal
kateb avec la danseuse qu'ils aillent à
poux zen originaire des philippines
et depuis trois ans en martinique on
entend parler chez bois 90 enchanté
tagalog ses deux longues natal dans
cette tour de babel des temps modernes